du géranium lierre simple c'est celui de
gaston voilà plan solaire pas beaucoup
d'arrosage plants de légumes de fruits
ou de fleurs il y en avait pour tous les
goûts
la deuxième édition de fête des plantes
s'est déroulée au mini saint denis
dimanche 9 mai toute la journée un
événement qui met à l'honneur le
jardinage
l'idée c'est de pouvoir permettre aux
gens avant les saints de glace je
récupérer soit des plants de légumes ou
de fruits ou beaucoup nous conseille
donc sans notre fête des plantes
il ya autant de prestataires privés que
d'associations qui sont présents plus de
1700 curieux sont venus à la recherche
de plantes pour leur jardin
il ya des chenilles à des plantes
de tomates de piment de mesures afin de
berges in et comme j'ai un petit jardin
alors donc cela m'intéressait de venir
ici http quoi je préfère plutôt là les
arbres n'empêche que là c'est plutôt des
fleurs et des jardins aussi en tout 27
stands étaient proposés aux visiteurs
entre horticulteurs paysagistes
agriculteurs ou associations locales ils
sont venus partager leur expérience et
savoir-faire
je viens de m'installer en tant
qu'agriculteur donc donc c'était un
moyen de me faire connaître dans le coin
et et puis puis de booster les ventes
aujourd'hui voilà c'est donc le moment
pour planter les semis comme le temps la
ciboulette l'aubergine la courgette ou
encore les épinards